broadly speaking on religion defining
the word very largely and what that
means to me is I choose to believe that
life makes sense that life is not just
chemistry not just chance so faith isn't
necessarily a belief in things it's just
an openness to believing something so
it's entertaining the language of
transcendentalism so I choose to believe
that life has transcendental meaning
rather than mere chemical mere
horizontal meaning I choose to have see
life vertically and to me it just makes
it a richer experience is it true is it
factually true well I don't know but no
one who has any kind of faith knows for
certain you fall in love with someone
you have nearly no idea what the future
holds for you you have a political faith
you have no idea if your system will
work out when you have faith in anything
it's just a disposition to be open and
to trust and to move forward that way
and I find a view of life that
entertains a transcendental that engages
with the transcendental it makes things
wealthy it also it makes things
wealthier in their significance and it
also it's a it's a way that makes
suffering more bearable that's one of
the great limits of secularism
secularism is incredibly powerful at
delivering things in the here and now a
good governance science human rights
these are all results of the application
of Reason and there are secular triumph
but secularism has nothing to say in the
face of death and in suffering so reason
for example is a great bloodsport in the
public arena you know atheists make for
great spectacles Christopher Hitchens
Richard docking in their public
performances it's amazing to hear them
but once you leave that spectacle in the
privacy of the night when we all walk
away all in our own progressively
getting older you know a subject to
disease and to suffering
suddenly reason is just a tool that
doesn't help you yeah if you believe
it's somehow in a way you don't fully
understand that doesn't make logical
sense somehow things make sense then
suffering is a small part of the can
verse of a bigger picture that you don't
see and in that bigger picture
somehow the suffering of children is a
part of the puzzle and you just accept
that and it may so it doesn't diminish
the suffering but it does put it in the
context so if only for that reason you
know an openness to it now I say that
I'm RELIGIOUS by an extremely critical
of organized religion you know what's
happening what has been happening
recently to the Roman Catholic Church I
am one of them who are delighted at all
these revelations of sexual abuse it's
an outrage of the church at value with
its reputation more than the sanctity of
his charges of these children and I
think ultimately it's better for the
church to be brought down several
several several pegs so I'm as critical
about organized religion you know of the
Roman Catholic Church of its homophobia
of its patriarchy of its sexism of its
true history of anti-semitism
I am totally okay with these attacks but
there's also something more afoot there
than just that and the same thing with
other religion whether two days in
Buddhism Hinduism they've all had their
excesses but nonetheless there's
something afoot in that kind of thinking
that I think augments life
now my background is totally secular I'm
from Quebec which is why which is the
most secular province in Canada was the
most Catholic then underwent something
called the quiet revolution which was in
a matter of a year or two people left
the church in droves and as I said it
jump from the most religious province to
the most secular my parents are children
of that revolution so I grew up in a
completely secular household and I
studied philosophy at a university which
is a great way of making you an atheist
a rabid atheist or at the very least
Arab an agnostic
what brought what made what brought me
to religion was well writing Life of Pi
and what brought me to writing life if I
was a trip to India India is this
continent civilization where for better
for worse religion is still is part of
the mainstream of life
you see temples mosques churches
everywhere these famous massive
pilgrimages in which you know millions
of Hindus join into it
it's a dazzling sight and it makes
really its mate it makes India a place
that's both a very real place in a
completely imaginary place India is one
of these places where I said there is a
concrete reality you know that you can
experience acts empirically and overlay
it on it is this extraordinary magining
country this fictitious it's
mythological country in most Western
countries that mythological layers been
completely stripped away which is why I
think India has been generous not only
to religions open to it there's more
religions I think per square inch and
you live in India than anywhere else for
better and for worse I'm saying but it's
also it's benefice it's extraordinary
honor for storytelling all kinds of
stories are still possible in India
which I think that'll last why for the
last twenty thirty years so much great
fiction has come out of India and once
again for better and for worse you know
Bollywood is the largest cinema industry
in the world now I think of the five
thousand movies made a year in what in
Bollywood you know 4999 occupy the last
bottom rungs are the worst movies ever
made but nonetheless stories that place
churns out stories like you you can't
believe so from someone who comes from a
Western background where we are so
taught to be reasonable we are so pushed
to be reasonable do
things for you know rational reasons
it's desiccating it dries you out which
is why I think some people go to India
and in a sense go wonderfully crazy they
suddenly want to become Buddhists they
want to become Hindus they start wearing
you know orange robes and and you know
praying to elephant-headed gods and they
do yoga and they they you know do funny
things well it's because you've been
dried out and suddenly you're drenched
in water it refreshes you so it was it
was India that brought me to that I saw
a face of religion aside to it that I'd
never seen before and decided to sort of
invest a well what would it mean to have
faith that crazy crazy phenomenon where
you are obdurate ly not reasonable what
would that do so I posited this
character who had lots of faith pi PI
Patel practices three religions and from
being just a conceit and artistic
conceit I fell in love with my with my
subject matter and I started being like
him and thinking well you know why not
entertain Brahma and Allah and Jesus and
Buddha and the gods of Jainism and you
know and why not sprites and and all
these other things why not why not
what's what's to be gained I remember
for years I volunteered in palliative
care care for the dying and I remember
thinking if you are dying in your bed
you know if your legs are tight like two
little sticks you have a mountain of a
stomach because and you're rotted by
disease you know you're this the flesh
on your face has melted away and you've
lost your hair and what's the point of
being reasonable why not believe in
whatever you know whatever Jesus Buddha
any one of these why not believe that
someone transcendentally loves you why
not believe that and so why not live
that way to entertain that notion that
the operating principle of the universe
is love why not believe that in the mean
time still be reasonable you know still
use reason to improve your life but once
reason fails you why not believe in this
great plan you know this great cosmic
plan where ultimate realization is this
massive act of love why not